Quisiera empezar citando una hermosa frase de Einstein,
para que la gente se sienta tranquila de que el gran científico del siglo XX
también está de acuerdo con nosotros, y también nos llama a esta acción.
Él dijo, "Un ser humano es parte de un todo, llamado por nosotros, universo.
Una parte limitada en tiempo y espacio,
se experimenta así mismo, sus pensamientos y sentimientos,
como algo separado del resto,
esa separación, es una especie de ilusión óptica de su conciencia.
Esta falsa ilusión es una especie de prisión para nosotros,
Nos limita a nuestros deseos personales y a dar cariño sólo a personas cercanas.
Nuestra tarea debe ser liberarnos de esta prisión ampliando nuestro círculo de compasión,
incluyendo a todas las criaturas vivientes y a toda la naturaleza en su belleza."
Esta percepción de Einstein es extrañamente cercana a la psicología Budista,
en donde la compasion es llamada Karuna,
y se define como: "la sensibilidad hacia el sufrimiento ajeno
y el correspondiente deseo de liberarlo de ese sufrimiento."
Se asemeja mucho al amor. El cual, es el deseo de hacer feliz al otro.
Eso requiere, por supuesto, que uno mismo sienta felicidad
y desee compartirla.
Esto es perfecto en que claramente, la preocupación por los demás,
es contraria al egoismo y al interés personal por la compasión,
y aún más, esto indica que aquellos atrapados en el círculo de la preocupación por si mismos,
sufren sin esperanza, mientras los compasivos son más libres
e implícitamente más felices.
El Dalai Lama a menudo dice que la compasión es su mejor amigo.
Lo ayuda cuando está agobiado con dolor y desesperanza.
La compasión lo ayuda a alejarse de la sensación de que su sufrimiento
es el más absoluto, y terrible que alguien haya tenido
y amplía su percepción del sufrimiento de otros,
incluso de aquellos culpables de su miseria y el de todas las criaturas.
De hecho, el sufrimiento es tan inmenso,
que su ser se hace menos y menos monumental.
Y él comienza a moverse más allá de la preocupación por si mismo, hacia una mayor preocupación por los demás.
Y esto inmediatamente levanta su ánimo,
a la vez que su valentía es estimulada a estar a la altura de las circumstancias.
Así que, usa su propio sufrimiento
como una forma de expandir su círculo de compasión.
Él es un muy buen compañero de Einstein, debo decir.
Quiero contarles una historia,
muy famosa en la tradición Hindú y Budista,
la del gran San Asanga.
quien vivió -- contemporáneo de San Agustín en el mundo occidental
era una especie de San Agustín budista.
Y Asanga vivió 800 años después de la era del Buda.
Él no estaba muy contento con las costumbres de los
budistas en India en ese tiempo.
Y dijo, "Estoy harto de todo ésto. Nadie está realmente viviendo la doctrina.
Están hablando de amor y compasión y sabiduría e iluminación espiritual,
pero todos son egoístas y patéticos.
Las enseñanzas de Buda han perdido su impulso.
Sé que el próximo Buda vendrá en unos miles de años más,
pero ya existe en algún Cielo, ese es Maitreya.
Me voy a ir a un retiro espiritual, voy a meditar
y rezar hasta que Buda Maitreya se aparezca ante mí,
y me entregue una enseñanza o algo
para revivir la práctica de la compasión en el mundo de hoy".
Entonces fué a su retiro. Y meditó por tres años
y no vió el próximo Buda Maitreya.
Y se fué indignado.
Y cuando se estaba yendo, vio a un hombre --
un pequeño hombre gracioso -- sentado al costado del camino que bajaba de la montaña.
Tenía un trozo de acero.
Lo frotaba con un paño.
Y eso le llamó la atención,
Y le preguntó, "¿Qué estás haciendo?"
Y el hombre le contestó, "Estoy haciendo una aguja"
Y él dijo: "Eso es ridículo. No puedes hacer una aguja
frotando un trozo de acero con un paño."
"¿Verdad?", le dijo el hombre, y le mostró un plato lleno de agujas.
Entonces él dijo : "Ok. Comprendo"
Volvío a su cueva. Meditó de nuevo.
Pasaron tres años, ninguna visión. Nuevamente, se va.
Comienza a bajar la montaña.
Mientras camina, ve a un pájaro hacer un nido en la pared de un acantilado.
Y donde está aterrizando para dejar las pequeñas ramas en el acantilado,
sus plumas frotan la roca, y había hecho un hoyo ya
de 15 a 20 cm en la roca. Había una grieta en la roca
debido al roce de las plumas de generaciones de pájaros.
Entonces dijo: "Está bien. Comprendo el punto". Y volvió a meditar.
Otros tres años.
Nuevamente, despúes de nueve años ninguna visión de Maitreya.
Y se retira, nuevamente. En esta ocasión, una gotera
había hecho una gran cavidad en la roca debido al impacto del goteo.
Y nuevamente vuelve a meditar. Y luego de 12 años, aún no tiene ninguna visión.
Está desesperado. Ni siquiera mira para su derecha o izquierda
para encontrar alguna visión alentadora.
Finalmente llega al pueblo. Está destruído.
De pronto se le acerca un perro,
se le acerca asi - un perro de aspecto terrible, de esos que pueden verse en países muy pobres,
incluso en USA, creo, en algunas áreas.
El perro luce muy mal.
Y a él le interesa por su aspecto patético,
trata de llamar su atención. Se sienta y observa al perro.
En las patas traseras el perro tiene una herida abierta.
Que parece incluso con gangrena.
Tiene larvas en la herida. Es terrible.
Y piensa, "¿Qué puedo hacer para sanar este perro?"
"Bueno, al menos puedo limpiar la herida y lavarlo"
Entonces lo lleva al agua, está a punto de limpiarlo,
y su atención de centra en las larvas.
Y mira las larvas, y éstas se ven algo tiernas.
Y todas esas larvas se ven felices allí en la herida del perro.
"Bueno, si limpio el perro, mataré a las larvas. ¿Cómo puede ser esto?"
"Así es. Soy una persona inútil y no existe Buda, ni Maitreya,
y todo es desesperanza.
Y ahora ¿voy a matar a estas larvas?"
Entonces, tuvo una idea brillante.
Tomó un trozo de algo, y corto un pedazo de su muslo
y lo puso en el suelo.
No estaba realmente pensado mucho en ASPCA (Sociedad Americana para prevenir la crueldad en animales).
Estaba atrapado por la situación.
Y pensó, "Tomaré las larvas y las pondré en esta porción de carne,
luego limpiaré las heridas, y luego -ya saben-
resolveré qué hacer con las larvas."
Y comienza a hacer eso. Pero no puede atrapar las larvas.
Las larvas se mueven de un lado a otro. Son difíciles de atrapar.
Y dice, "Bueno, pondré mi lengua en la herida del perro.
Y todas las larvas saltarán en mi cálida lengua.
El perro ya está casi acabado.
Luego las escupiré una por una sobre el trozo de carne."
Entonces se agacha y acerca su lengua de esta manera.
Tuvo que cerrar sus ojos, era algo muy repulsivo, oloroso y todo lo demás.
Y de pronto se escucha un ruido como "pfft".
salta hacia atrás y allí, por supuesto, aparece Buda Maitreya.
En una hermosa visión como luces de arco iris, dorada, adornado con joyas, un cuerpo de plasma,
Vé como una visión mística exquisita.
"Oh", exclama y hace una reverencia.
Pero, siendo humano, está inmediatamente pensando en su siguiente queja.
A medida que se está levantando de la reverencia dice,
"Mi Señor, estoy muy feliz de verlo, pero ¿dónde ha estado durante estos 12 años?...
...¿qué es esto?"
Y Maitreya dice: "He estado contigo. ¿Quién crees que estaba haciendo las agujas
y haciendo los nidos y provocando las gotas sobre la roca, Sr. torpe?"
(Risas)
"Buscando a Buda en persona.", le dijo.
Y le dijo: "No tuviste, hasta éste momento, verdadera compasión.
Y, hasta que no tengas verdadera compasión, no puedes reconocer el amor."
En sánscrito, Maitreya significa amor, el amor afectuoso.
Asanga lo miraba con incredulidad.
y le dijo "Si no me crees, sólo llévame contigo."
Entonces tomó a Maitreya -- que se encogió del tamaño de una pelota --
y lo puso sobre su hombro.
Y corrió hacia el mercado del pueblo gritando: "Alegría, alegría.
El próximo Buda ha llegado adelantadose a todas las predicciones. Aquí está."
Y de inmediato le comenzaron a lanzar piedras --
No era en Chautauqua. Era en otro pueblo --
porque veían a este hombre flaco con aspecto de demente místico,
algo como un hippie, con una pierna sangrando y un perro moribundo en su hombro,
gritando que el próximo Buda había llegado.
Naturalmente, lo persiguieron hasta las afueras del pueblo.
Pero en las afueras del pueblo, una señora mayor que limpiaba las fosas de cadáveres,
vío un pie adornado en una flor de loto y al perro en su hombro,
vío el pie de Maitreya adornado, y le ofreció una flor.
Eso lo animó, y se fué con Maitreya.
Maitreya entonces lo llevó a un determinado cielo,
la manera en que un mito budista se revela,
Y Maitreya lo mantuvo en este paraíso por cinco años,
enseñándole cinco complicados libros
sobre la metodología de cómo se cultiva la compasión.
Asi que pensé en compartir con ustedes este método, o uno de ellos.
El famoso, es llamado "Método causal de los siete pasos para el desarrollo de la compasion"
En primer lugar se comienza por meditar y visualizar que todos los seres están con uno,
y todos -- aún los animales -- tienen forma humana.
Los animales están en una de sus vidas humanas. Los humanos son humanos.
Y entre ellos están tus amigos y seres queridos.
piensas también en tus enemigos y en aquellos que son neutrales.
Y luego tratas de decir, "Bueno, las personas que yo amo,
después de todo, ellos son buenos conmigo.
Tuve peleas con ellos. Algunas veces fueron poco amigables.
Me irrité. Los hermanos pueden pelear. Padres e hijos pueden pelear.
de cierto modo, ellos me gustan mucho porque son buenos conmigo.
Mientas que a los neutrales no los conozco. Todos podrían ser buenos.
Y luego los enemigos, no me agradan porque son malos conmigo.
Pero ellos son amables para alguien. Yo podría ser uno de esos."
los Budistas, por supuesto, piensan que todos hemos tenido infinitas vidas anteriores,
los Budistas en realidad piensan que todos hemos sido familiares unos de otros,
y cada uno, por lo tanto todos ustedes, desde el punto de vista del Budismo,
en alguna vida anterior, aunque tú no lo recuerdes y yo tampoco lo recuerde,
han sido mi madre, por lo cual me disculpo por lo problemas que les causé,
incluso, yo también he sido tu madre.
He sido mujer, y la madre de cada unos de ustedes en una vida previa,
esa es la manera en que los Budistas reflexionan.
Entonces, mi madre, en ésta vida es realmente maravillosa. Pero todos ustedes en cierto modo
son parte de la madre eterna.
Tú me diste esa expresión, la madre eterna, tú dijiste. Eso es maravilloso.
Esa es la manera en que los Budistas lo hacen.
Un creyente, cristiano, puede pensar que todos los seres, incluso mis enemigos, son hijos de Dios.
Entonces, en ese sentido, estamos relacionados.
Asi que, ellos primero crean ésta base de igualdad.
que de cierta manera la reducimos a quienes amamos --
en la meditación -- abrimos nuestra mente a aquellos que no conocemos.
Y definitivamente reducimos la hostilidad y el "yo no quiero ser compasivo con ellos"
a aquellos que pensamos que son malvados, que odiamos y que no nos agradan.
Por consiguiente, no odiamos a nadie. Igualamos. Eso es muy imporante.
Y lo siguiente que hacemos, es lo que se llama reconocimiento materno.
Y eso es, que pensamos que cada uno es familiar, como la familia.
Nos expandimos. Tomamos el sentimiento de recordar a mamá
y, en la meditación, lo hacemos con todos los seres.
Y vemos a la madre en cada ser.
Y vemos esa mirada que la madre tiene en su rostro,
esa mirada a su hijo que es un milagro
que ella ha producido desde su propio cuerpo, siendo un mamífero,
donde ella tiene verdadera compasión, realmente es el otro, y con el que se identifica completamente.
A menudo la vida de ese otro es más importante para ella que su propia vida.
Y esa la razón por la cual es la más poderosa forma de -- altruismo.
La madre es el modelo de todo altruismo para los seres humanos,
en las tradiciones espirituales.
Entonces, reflexionamos hasta que podemos de alguna manera, ver esa expresión materna en todos los demás.
La gente se ríe de mi porque yo solía decir eso.
Yo solía pensar en la madre de Cheney como mi madre,
cuando, por supuesto, yo estaba enojado con él por de todos esas atrocidades cometidas en Iraq.
Yo solía pensar en George Bush. Se ve muy adorable con aspecto de mamá.
Tiene sus pequeñas orejas y sonríe y te mece en sus brazos.
Y tu piensas que te está cuidando.
Y luego Saddam Hussein, su bigote es un gran problema.
Pero tú piensas que es mamá.
Y esa es la manera como lo haces. Tomas cada ser que te parezca raro,
y luego ves cómo podría parecerte familiar.
Y haces eso por un rato hasta que realmente lo sientas.
Puedes sentir la familiaridad en todo los seres.
Nadie parece un extraterrestre. Ellos no son "otros".
reduces el sentimiento de diferencia hacia los demás.
Luego avanzas desde allí para recordar la bondad de las madres en general,
si puedes, recuerda la bondad de tu propia madre,
recuerda la bondad de tu pareja,
o, si eres mamá, como tú serías con tus niños.
comienzas a ponerte muy sentimental, desarrollas un sentimentalismo intenso.
Incluso llorarás, quizás, con gratitud y amabilidad.
Y luego conectas eso con el sentimiento de que cada uno tiene esa posibilidad maternal.
Cada ser, incluso el que parezca más miserable, puede ser maternal.
Y entonces, el tercer paso lo das hacia lo que se denomina sentimiento de gratitud.
Quieres retribuir esa bondad que todos los seres han mostrado hacia ti.
Y luego, el cuarto paso, te mueves a lo que se denomina amor.
En cada una de estas etapas, ésta meditación puede tomar
dependiendo de como lo hagas, semanas, meses o días o puedes hacerlo de una sola vez.
Y luego piensas en lo amoroso que son los seres cuando están felices,
cuando están satisfechos.
todos se ven hermosos cuando están internamente sintiéndose felices.
Su rostro no se ve asi. Todos se ven feos cuando estan enojados,
pero cuando están felices se ven bellos.
asi que ves a los seres en su felicidad potencial,
sientes tanto amor por ellos, que los quieres ver felices, aún a tus enemigos,
y, en realidad, es lógico que lo quieras -
¿pensamos que Jesus no fué practico cuando dijo ama tu enemigo ?
Él lo dice, y pensamos que no es práctico,
es algo espiritual e improbable y decimos "Que bien por Él pero yo no puedo hacerlo"
Pero en realidad es práctico,
Si amas a tu enemigo, significa que quieres que tu enemigo sea feliz,
Si tu enemigo fuera feliz, ¿por qué se molestaría en ser tu enemigo?
Que aburrido es seguirte y molestarte.
En lugar de relajarse y pasarla bien.
asi que, tiene sentido el querer que tu enemigo sea feliz,
dejarán de ser tus enemigos porque es mucho problema.
De todas formas, eso es amor,
y finalmente, el quinto paso es compasión, compasión universal.
y aquí es donde ves la realidad de los seres.
los miras y verás quienes son,
te darás cuenta que la mayor parte del tiempo son infelices.
verás personas con el ceño fruncido
te darás cuenta que ni siquiera tienen compasión por ellos mismos.
su dirección esta determinda por su responsabilidad y obligaciones.
"Tengo que conseguir eso. Necesito más. No valgo nada. Debo hacer algo"
y corren estresados de un lado a otro.
piensan de alguna manera como machos, se auto-disciplinan fuertemente.
Pero en realidad son crueles con ellos mismos.
por consiguiente, son crueles e implacables con los demás.
nunca reciben comentarios positivos.
Cuanto más éxito y poder tengan,
más infelices son,
Y es aquí donde sientes verdadera compasión por ellos.
y luego sientes que debes hacer algo.
es la motivación -
y lo que escojas hacer, esperando que seas más práctico
que el pobre Asanga tratando de sacar las larvas del perro,
por que él tuvo esa motivacion, y sin importar quién estaba en frente,
él quizo ayudar.
por supuesto que no fue práctico. Pudo haber buscado la ASPCA en el pueblo
y encontrar ayuda científica para perros y larvas,
estoy seguro que luego lo hizo. Eso sólo indica un estado de conciencia.
y el próximo paso - el sexto paso más allá de la compasión universal -
el cúal es, cuando te sientes realmente unido a las necesidades de otros,
y también sientes compasión por ti mismo.
y no - no sólo es sentimental - podrías sentir miedo de algo.
Alguna persona malvada se está haciendo asi mismo más y más infeliz,
y está siendo más y más cruel con otras personas
y está consiguiendo ser castigado en el futuro de muhas maneras.
en el Buddhismo, lo atraparán en una vida futura.
por supuesto que en una religión teísta, ellos son castigados por Dios u otra cosa.
en el materialismo, piensan que se pueden salir con la suya al no existir,
al morir en este mundo, pero no,
ellos renacen, o algo así,
no importa, no ahondaré en eso.
El próximo paso es el llamado responsabilidad universal.
La Carta de la Compasión es muy importante
Debe guiarnos a desarrollar a través de la compasión verdadera,
lo que es llamado, la responsabilidad universal.
Lo que significa que las enseñanzas del Dalai Lama,
que las dicta por doquier, dice,
que esa es la religión común de la humanidad, amabilidad,
amabilidad significa responsabilidad universal.
lo que significa que lo que le suceda a otras personas nos pasa a nosotros,
somos responsables de eso, y debemos tomarlo,
y hacer lo que podamos en cualquier nivel
en el mas pequeño nivel que podamos,
debemos hacerlo absolutamente. No hay manera de No hacerlo.
y finalmente ésto nos llevara a una nueva dirección en la vida
en la que vivimos en igualdad para nosotros y otros,
nos damos cuenta de nuestra felicidad -
y estamos alegres y felices.
no debes pensar que la compasión te hace miserable.
la compasión te hace felíz.
cuando tienes gran compasión, la primera persona que es feliz eres tú,
aún cuando todavía no hayas hecho nada por nadie.
tan sólo el cambio de conciencia hace algo por otros,
ellos pueden sentir ésta nueva cualidad en tí,
ésto les ayuda y les da un ejemplo,
y ése reloj sin compasión me está mostrando que se acabó,
asi que practiquen compasión, lean la carta, denla a conocer,
y desarróllalo en tí mismo.
No sólo pienses, oh, bueno, siento compasión o no siento compasión,
te éstas estancando,
Puedes desarrollar ésto. Puedes reducir la No-compasión,
la crueldad, la insensibilidad, la negligencia hacia otros.
Toma responsabilidad universal por ellos
Y entonces, no sólo Dios y la mama eterna reirán,
Karen Armstrong también reirá.
Muchas Gracias.